Welcome to another Stories From The
Stores
Now today we're joined by curator Alex Rose
and she's told me that this
instrument can measure ozone.
Alex, how does it work?
Ozone is a gas that's produced up in the stratosphere,
so that's a layer of the
Earth's atmosphere that's between
10 and 50 kilometers up and ozone absorbs UV light from the Sun.
Okay, like a layer of sun cream?
Basically like a layer of sun cream,
and that's the principle that this instrument uses to measure ozone.
It was made in 1924 by a university professor
called Gordon Dobson, in his shed, and he realized that
no one had taken regular measurements of ozone and
he wanted to create a more continuous data set.
So he constructed
this instrument to do that.
It would have been mounted so that you could adjust the height,
there's a scale on the side where you can see what angle it's pointing at
so that you could angle it at the Sun or whatever angle you wanted.
Is that why it's got a bubble meter?
Yeah, exactly so that he could calculate the height.
It has a filter at this end that
separated out the wavelengths of light
that he was interested in recording.
There's a prism here that splits
out the light, and then the readings
would have been taken on a photographic
plate that sat just down there.
Okay so he's taking all of these readings,
did he find that hole in the ozone layer?
He didn't because in 1924 it didn't exist.
What he did discover was that the levels of ozone weren't constant
they fluctuated a lot, so they varied daily,
they varied annually, seasonally.
So did they use this object to discover the
hole in the ozone layer?
It was a modern version of this instrument stationed at Antarctica
that a number of British scientists were looking at
measurements from and they realised that
levels of ozone were much lower than
they were expecting and were declining.
So after the initial findings in the mid
1980s there was a big international
research project that confirmed the
findings that there was a hole in the ozone layer
and the world came together
to ban the use of CFC in the manufacturing industry
which was the cause of the hole.
And that's all thanks to Dobson.
Exactly, so scientists still use his name every time they take measurements
because the modern versions of this instrument are called Dobson meters by scientists
and the unit of measurement for atmospheric ozone
in fact bears his name, it's called the
Dobson!